This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Sometimes when I'm driving or walking around the Bay Area, I'm astounded by every park I see. In a place where each parcel of land could be worth millions of dollars, there are these shared green spaces that are at least theoretically meant for everyone. I feel the same about libraries. They're like miracles. Take a kid to a library for the first time and you'll see. It is a temple dedicated to the concept of sharing,
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。有时当我开车或步行漫步于湾区时，我会被看到的每一个公园所震撼。在每一块土地都可能价值数百万美元的地方，有这些共享的绿地，它们至少在理论上是属于所有人的。我对图书馆也有同样的感受。它们就像是奇迹。带一个孩子第一次去图书馆，你就会明白。这是一座献给分享概念的圣殿，
you know, books, sure, but also just sharing space. Eric Kleinenberg is a sociologist and bestselling author who makes a convincing case that a healthy community is not simply held together by shared values, but by shared spaces. Physical, real-world locations where people across all strata and ages and races and creeds bump into each other and form connections.
你知道，当然是书，但也有纯粹的共享空间。埃里克·克莱嫩伯格是一位社会学家兼畅销书作家，他提出了一个令人信服的观点：一个健康的社区不仅仅靠共同的价值观维系，更是靠共享的空间维系。那些真实存在于现实世界的场所，让各个阶层、各个年龄、各种种族和信仰的人们在这里偶遇并建立联系。
He also makes a convincing case that we are neglecting our shared spaces, what he calls our social infrastructure. And this is a shame because our social infrastructure could help solve or at least mitigate some of our most pressing challenges, like isolation, polarization, education, crime, and even climate change. He lays out his manifesto in a great book he wrote
他还提出了一个令人信服的观点，即我们正在忽视我们的共享空间，也就是他所说的我们的社会基础设施。这真是一个遗憾，因为我们的社会基础设施可以帮助解决或至少缓解我们最紧迫的一些挑战，比如孤立、极化、教育、犯罪，甚至是气候变化。他在他写的一本好书里阐述了他的宣言
called Palaces for the People. I think it's just brilliant So I asked him to chat with me My name is Eric Kleinanberg. I'm a professor of sociology at New York University And I'm also the author of a book called Palaces for the People How social infrastructure can help fight inequality polarization and the decline of civic life. So where does the phrase palaces for the people come from? It comes from Andrew Carnegie, and I have to tell you that I was a little nervous about
名为《为人民的宫殿》。我认为它太棒了，所以我邀请他来和我聊聊。我叫埃里克·克莱嫩伯格。我是纽约大学社会学教授，我也是一本名为《为人民的宫殿：社会基础设施如何帮助对抗不平等、极化和公民生活的衰落》的的书的作者。那么“为人民的宫殿”这个短语是从哪里来的呢？它来自安德鲁·卡内基，我必须告诉你，我当时对
using that title because Carnegie, as you might know, has a pretty mixed record when it comes to human decency. He was really a pretty ruthless capitalist, you know, Titan of the Gilded Age among the wealthiest people in the world when he lived famous for breaking strikes in a pretty vicious way and doing things that probably promoted inequality in many parts of the world. But Carnegie was also an immigrant. He was born in Scotland and came to the United States.
使用这个标题有点紧张，因为正如你可能知道的那样，卡内基在人类道德方面有着相当复杂的记录。他实际上是一个相当冷酷的资本家，你知道的，镀金时代的巨头，在他生活的时代是世界上最富有的人之一，以相当恶劣的方式镇压罢工而闻名，并且在世界许多地方做出了可能加剧不平等的事情。但卡内基同时也是一个移民。他在苏格兰出生并来到美国。
And he believed that one of the amazing things about the U.S. is that it created institutions where people could get ahead in life and achieve something greater than they could have achieved in their home countries. And he wanted to help build a social institution that would do that even better. And so over the course of his life, he helped to fund more than 2,500 libraries around the world, about 1,700 of which were in the United States. And he called the greatest of them, palaces for the people. The library, as Carnegie saw it, was a place where a person who worked in a factory or
他相信美国最了不起的事情之一，就是它创造了一些机构，让人能够在生活中脱颖而出，取得比在祖国所能取得的更大的成就。他想帮忙建立一个能够把这件事做得更好的社会机构。因此，在他的一生中，他资助了全球2500多座图书馆，其中大约1700座在美国。他把其中最好的那些称为“为人民的宫殿”。在卡内基看来，图书馆是一个地方，让一个在工厂工作的人，或者
lived in a tenement building and experienced life as crowded and uncomfortable and rushed. Most of the time could go and escape all of that. And so the great Carnegie libraries have high ceilings and big windows and spacious rooms where a person can go and read and think and achieve something that they feel proud of. And I just thought that was a beautiful phrase when I heard it, and it became a title for the book. You talk about libraries as being the perfect example of what you call social infrastructure.
住在廉租房里、体验着拥挤、不舒服和匆忙生活的人。大多数时候都可以去那里逃避这一切。因此，伟大的卡内基图书馆拥有高挑的天花板、巨大的窗户和宽敞的房间，人们可以在那里阅读、思考，并取得让他们感到自豪的成就。当我听到这个词时，我只觉得这是一个美丽的短语，它后来成了这本书的书名。你谈到图书馆是你所谓的社会基础设施的完美例子。
So what is social infrastructure more broadly? Yeah, well, it's a pretty new concept, especially in the United States. But when I use social infrastructure, what I mean to say is that there is a set of physical places and institutions that shape our social life. And social infrastructure is just as real as the infrastructure for water or for power or for communications. But we haven't been able to see it because we don't have a concept for it. And what I've learned over the course of my work as a social scientist is that when we
那么，更广泛地说，什么是社会基础设施呢？是的，这是一个相当新的概念，尤其是在美国。但当我使用“社会基础设施”时，我的意思是存在着一组塑造我们社会生活的物理场所和机构。社会基础设施和水、电或通信的基础设施一样真实。但我们一直没能看到它，因为我们没有这个概念。作为一名社会科学家，我在工作过程中了解到，当我们
live in places where we invest in social infrastructure, places like libraries or parks, schools, athletic fields, we reap all kinds of benefits. We become far more likely to interact with people around us, whether they are friends and family or neighbors who we haven't gotten to know. And when we don't invest in social infrastructure, if we neglect it, if we let it fall apart, we tend to grow more isolated.
生活在那些我们投资于社会基础设施的地方——像图书馆、公园、学校、运动场这样的地方——我们会收获各种各样的好处。我们更有可能与周围的人互动，无论是朋友、家人还是我们还不了解的邻居。而当我们不投资于社会基础设施，如果我们忽视它，如果我们任由它破败，我们往往会变得更加孤立。
You mentioned that social infrastructure is more invisible than hard infrastructure. How was it that you were able to see it for the first time? Yeah, well, the first time I thought about social infrastructure was when I was a graduate student, doing a research project on a heat wave in Chicago that was the city I grew up in. And I was puzzled by something very strange in this heatwave. It was a
你提到社会基础设施比硬基础设施更隐形。你是怎么第一次看到它的？是的，我第一次思考社会基础设施是在我读研究生的时候，当时我在做一个关于芝加哥热浪的研究项目，芝加哥是我长大的城市。在那场热浪中，有些非常奇怪的事情让我感到困惑。那是
disaster in 1995 that killed more than 700 people. And as a social scientist, I was interested in understanding the patterns. The first pattern I observed was the most predictable thing that could happen in a disaster. And that's that the poor neighborhoods, the segregated neighborhoods on the south sides and the west sides of Chicago had the highest death rate by far. And that's not interesting. It's kind of politically important because it's a story about where resources go and where vulnerability is, but scientifically it's what you would expect. But when I looked even more closely at the patterns, something really puzzling did emerge.
一场发生在1995年的灾难，夺去了700多人的生命。作为一名社会科学家，我有兴趣了解其中的规律。我观察到的第一个规律是灾难中最容易发生的事情。那就是芝加哥南部和西部贫穷的、被隔离的社区死亡率高居榜首。这并不奇怪。从政治上讲，它很重要，因为它讲述了资源流向何处以及脆弱性在哪里，但从科学上讲，这是意料之中的事。然而，当我更仔细地观察这些规律时，一件真正令人困惑的事情确实浮现了。
And that is that there were a bunch of neighborhoods that demographically looked like they should have fared very badly in the disaster, but in fact proved to be strikingly resilient. They were safer even than the most affluent neighborhoods on the north side. And even more interestingly, there were these pairs of neighborhoods where the demographics were identical,
那就是有一群社区，从人口统计学上看，它们本应该在这场灾难中表现得非常糟糕，但事实上却被证明具有惊人的韧性。它们甚至比北部最富裕的社区还要安全。更有趣的是，有这样几对社区，它们的人口结构完全相同，
like the same proportion of old people and poor people and African-American people. And they were separated by justice street. They literally neighboring neighborhoods. And one neighborhood would have an astronomically high death rate and the other would be one of the safest places in Chicago. And the numbers alone couldn't tell the story of what was going on. So in kind of classic, you know, ethnographer style, I started traveling around and spending time in the neighborhoods. And
比如相同比例的老年人、穷人和非裔美国人。它们只隔了一条街。它们真的是毗邻的社区。其中一个社区的死亡率高得惊人，而另一个社区则是芝加哥最安全的地方之一。仅凭数字无法说明到底发生了什么。因此，按照经典的、你知道的人类学家的风格，我开始四处旅行，在这些社区里度过时间。
what I observed is that the places that had low death rates turned out to have a robust social infrastructure. They had sidewalks and streets that were well taken care of. They had neighborhood libraries. They had community organizations. They had grocery stores and shops and cafes that drew people out of their home and into public life. What that meant is that on a daily basis, people got to know each other pretty well.
我观察到的是，那些死亡率很低的社区，结果证明拥有强大的社会基础设施。它们的行人和街道得到了很好的维护。它们有社区图书馆。它们有社区组织。它们有杂货店、商店和咖啡馆，将人们吸引出家门，融入公共生活。这意味着在日常生活中，人们对彼此有了相当多的了解。
They used the social infrastructure to socialize. And so when this crisis happened in Chicago, they knew who was likely to be sick, who should have been outside but wasn't. And that meant they knew who's doored and not gone and who to help. Meanwhile, in the neighborhoods that had really high death rates, the social infrastructure was depleted. There were a lot of abandoned properties, empty lots, abandoned
他们利用社会基础设施进行社交。因此，当芝加哥发生这场危机时，他们知道谁可能生病了，谁本应该在外面却没有在外面。这意味着他们知道谁的门没开、谁没去过以及该去帮谁。与此同时，在死亡率极高的社区里，社会基础设施已经枯竭。那里有许多废弃的房产、空地、废弃的
houses. Sidewalks were often cracked and broken, very little commercial life, not a lot of institutions there. And that meant that people were likely to stay home. And unfortunately, during the heat wave, this was a deadly thing to do. And I realized at the end of that project, actually it was social infrastructure, not the traditional hard infrastructures that we normally think of that explained who lived and who died that we can Chicago.
房屋。人行道经常破裂损坏，商业活动非常少，也没有多少机构。这意味着人们往往会呆在家里。不幸的是，在热浪期间，这是一件致命的事情。那个项目结束时我意识到，实际上是社会基础设施，而不是我们通常认为的传统硬基础设施，解释了我们在芝加哥谁生谁死。
The Chicago heat wave convinced Eric that social infrastructure was vital to public health and safety in cities. And so years later, when Superstorm Sandy hit the New York area, he wanted to make sure people knew that it was going to take more than just seawalls to make New York safer and more resilience in the face of climate change. He got involved in a competition sponsored by the federal government called Rebuild by Design. And again and again, he emphasized to the various design teams the importance of building infrastructure that brings people together. But one day, I was taking one team around a neighborhood in Brooklyn and they came up to me and they said, you know, Eric, we've been listening to talk about social infrastructure
芝加哥热浪让埃里克确信，社会基础设施对城市中的公共健康和安全至关重要。因此，几年后，当超级风暴桑迪袭击纽约地区时，他想确保人们知道，面对气候变化，要让纽约更安全、更有韧性，需要的不仅仅是海堤。他参与了一项由联邦政府赞助的名为“通过设计重建”的竞赛。他一次又一次地向各个设计团队强调建设能将人们聚集在一起的基础设施的重要性。但有一天，我正带着一个团队参观布鲁克林的某个社区，他们走到我面前对我说：“你知道吗，埃里克，我们一直在听你谈论社会基础设施
and how important it is. We realize that the design that we're going to propose for this competition is going to be right in line with that. We have this idea for something we're calling a resilient center. I said, wow, that sounds amazing. Who wouldn't want a resilient center? Can you tell me about it? They said, okay, so this resilient center is going to be a nice building that will put in a vulnerable neighborhood
以及它是多么重要。我们意识到，我们为这次竞赛提出的设计将完全符合这一理念。我们有一个想法，我们称之为韧性中心。”我说：“哇，听起来太棒了。谁会不想要一个韧性中心呢？你能跟我讲讲吗？”他们说：“好，这个韧性中心将是一座漂亮的建筑，我们将把它放在康涅狄格州一个小镇的一个脆弱社区里。
in the town in Connecticut. And we see it as a prototype that we could build in cities all over the country. And it will be open as much as possible. It will be spacious. It will have flexible uses, it will be staffed by personnel who are aggressively welcoming, let's say. Their job is really to make everyone feel like they're welcome all the time.
我们将其视为一个可以建立在全国各地城市中的原型。它将尽可能地开放。它将是宽敞的。它将具有灵活的用途，并且将配备热情得可以说是极具进取心的工作人员。他们的工作就是真正让每个人随时都感到受欢迎。”
We know that very young people and very old people are most at risk and most need kind of resilience at home because they might not be as mobile as other parts of the population. So, we're going to have all kinds of special programming for kids, like things like story time in the morning. And since we know the kids come with caretakers, you know, parents or grandparents or sitters, we'll do something for them too. Maybe we'll give them, you know know access to Wi-Fi and computers and we really see this this resilient center as an amazing new institution
我们知道极年轻的人和极年老的人风险最大，最需要在家里获得某种韧性，因为他们的行动可能不如人口的其他部分那么灵活。所以，我们将为孩子们举办各种特殊的活动，比如早上的故事时间。既然我们知道孩子们是由看护人陪同来的，你知道的，父母、祖父母或保姆，我们也会为他们做点什么。也许我们会给他们，你知道的，提供使用无线网络和电脑的权限，我们真的将这个韧性中心视为一个了不起的新机构，
that could strengthen people who live in every vulnerable part of the country. And I said to them, wow you know that's an amazing idea because I'm a professor and I'm used to telling people first that their ideas are amazing. And then I said, have you ever heard of a library? Because clearly they had just redesigned the wheel. And at first I thought it was a little crazy, but, I realized that it was completely predictable and forgivable because we live in a moment where so many people think of the library as an obsolete institution right? We think it's a relic from another part of our history and that it's not used history and that it's not used much by anyone, even though it turns out that nothing could be further from the truth.
它可以增强生活在全国每个脆弱地区的人们的力量。”我对他们说：“哇，你知道这是一个了不起的主意，因为我是一名教授，我习惯了先告诉别人他们的想法有多棒。”然后我说：“你听说过图书馆吗？”因为很显然，他们刚刚重新发明了轮子。起初我以为这有点疯狂，但我意识到这是完全可以预料和原谅的，因为我们生活在一个这样的时代：许多人认为图书馆是一个过时的机构，对吗？我们认为它是我们历史另一部分的遗迹，没有人会多大程度上使用它，即使事实证明没有任何事情比这更远离真相。
And so I realized that I really needed to spend more time in libraries myself and to write something that reminded people just all of the extraordinary things that libraries do as social infrastructure, because they're such valuable institutions for us, and yet they are taken for granted and in many parts of the world and the country on the chopping block. And so Eric started visiting libraries all over the country. He went to small town libraries and suburban libraries, big city libraries designed by famous architects and small neighborhood libraries in little brick buildings. And he's time he found lots of people using the library and many of them using it in some pretty surprising ways.
因此我意识到，我确实需要花更多时间亲自去图书馆，写一些东西来提醒人们图书馆作为社会基础设施所做的所有非凡的事情，因为它们对我们来说是如此宝贵的机构，然而它们却被视为理所当然，在世界和国家的许多地方都面临着被砍掉的命运。于是，埃里克开始参观全国各地的图书馆。他去了小镇图书馆和郊区图书馆、由著名建筑师设计的大城市图书馆，以及小砖房里的微型社区图书馆。每一次他都发现有很多人在使用图书馆，其中许多人以相当令人惊讶的方式使用它。
One of my favorite programs came from the Brooklyn Library where they created the library lanes virtual bowling league, which meets weekly in the basements and kind of community centers inside libraries, the kind of common rooms. And the context for understanding why these things are so amazing is that about 20 years ago, a great social scientist named Robert Putnam wrote a book called Bowling Alone. The complaint was like people used to do things together collectively in formal groups and now everyone like in Putnam's nightmare from 1999, everybody was just watching television at home together in the living room, you know, which I now think of, now that I have kids
我最喜欢的项目之一来自布鲁克林图书馆，他们创建了图书馆球道虚拟保龄球联赛，每周在图书馆的地下室和某种社区中心、也就是公共休息室里聚会。理解为什么这些事情如此了不起的背景是，大约20年前，一位伟大的社会学家名叫罗伯特·帕特南，写了一本名为《独自打保龄球》的书。当时的抱怨就像是人们过去常常在正式团体中集体做事情，而现在每个人，就像帕特南1999年的噩梦里那样，每个人都只是在起居室里一起在家看电视，你知道的，我现在觉得——既然我有了拥有自己移动设备的孩子的
who have like their own mobile devices, that's like a socialist utopian fantasy to me. Like, oh my God, if only we could have a night together watching the same screen, it would be amazing. But what happened in Brooklyn is that these kind of brilliant people realize there's all these older people who live alone in neighborhoods around New York City, and they're exactly the people who would have been most likely to die in the heatwave in Chicago.
父母，这对我来说就像是一个社会主义乌托邦式的幻想。就像，哦天哪，如果我们能有一个晚上一起看同一个屏幕，那就太棒了。但在布鲁克林发生的事情是，这些聪明绝顶的人意识到，有这么多老年人独自住在纽约市周围的社区里，他们正是最有可能在芝加哥热浪中死亡的那群人。
And they have to do special programming for them. And some older people are bookish and want to do arts things, but some actually want to be physical and exercise and be social that way, and they need to be. So they created this program called Library Lanes and once a week this group of older people come together and they put on actual bowling jerseys with their library name on it and a librarian connects an Xbox to a television
他们必须为他们做特殊的编程。有些老年人喜欢读书，想做艺术方面的事情，但有些人实际上想要进行体力活动、锻炼并以这种方式进行社交，他们需要这样做。因此，他们创建了一个名为“图书馆球道”的项目，每周一次，这群老年人聚在一起，穿上印有他们图书馆名字的真正的保龄球球衣，图书管理员将Xbox连接到电视上，
and they compete against other library teams. And I'll tell you, like, I'm a sports junkie, I spend my weekends following my son around to his soccer games, I like to go to professional and college games. I'm not lying, Roman, when I tell you that, like, I haven't been to a sporting event as exciting and collectively effervescent
他们与其他图书馆团队竞争。我告诉你，就像，我是一个体育迷，我的周末都在陪着我儿子去踢足球比赛，我喜欢去观看职业比赛和大学比赛。罗曼，我没有对你撒谎，当我说，就像，我从来没有去过像布鲁克林东区这场不可思议的比赛那样令人兴奋且具有集体狂热的体育赛事，
at the sociological praise as this incredible match in East New York, where where this group of older bowlers came back and crushed it in the final frames to win their match. It was amazing. Oh, that's so great. We boldly intern him this is not exactly what people think of when they think of a library. And probably isn't, certainly wasn't what Andrew Carnegie
用社会学的赞美来说，这群老年保龄球手在最后的决胜局中卷土重来并大获全胜，赢得了他们的比赛。太棒了。哦，太棒了。我们大胆地插一句，这绝对不是人们想到图书馆时所想到的。而且可能不是，当然也绝对不是安德鲁·卡内基
thought of when he thought of the library. So what are some other examples of how a library is being used today outside of the conventional like you get a library card, you get books and stuff. Yeah, my goodness. I was just thinking about Andrew Carnegie, you know, being told about all the things that these palaces for the people have turned into. I hope you would like them. I mean, let me tell you about some of the things that I saw.
想到图书馆时的想法。那么，除了诸如你拿到借书证、拿到书之类的传统用法之外，今天人们如何使用图书馆还有哪些其他例子？天哪。我刚才还在想安德鲁·卡内基，你知道的，当被告知这些为人民的宫殿已经变成了什么样的时候。我希望他会喜欢它们。我的意思是，让我告诉你我看到的一些事情。
I mean, first of all, the library's remain places where lots of early literacy development happens. And every morning, often before the library would open, the librarians would open the doors for groups of preschoolers or kids from day camp who would come in with teachers and get exposed to books and be told stories. And there are so many people who just can't afford books and don't have books at home or have parents who speak another language. And they come to the library to learn to read and to learn to love books. And that's amazing. Probably Carnegie anticipated that.
我的意思是，首先，图书馆仍然是许多早期识字能力发展发生的地方。每天早晨，通常在图书馆开门之前，图书管理员会为学龄前儿童群体或日间夏令营的孩子们打开大门，孩子们在老师的带领下进来接触书籍并听故事。有太多的人根本买不起书，家里没有书，或者父母说的是另一种语言。他们来到图书馆学习阅读并学会热爱书籍。这太棒了。卡内基可能预料到了这一点。
But he probably would not have seen that, you know, libraries have now become the places where people who used to be incarcerated come more than any other institution to search for a job, to get help putting a resume together. He probably would not have anticipated that libraries have become the places where there's more instruction for English as a second language, more citizenship classes than any other public institution. He probably didn't anticipate that libraries would do
但他可能没有看到，你知道的，图书馆现在已经成为了曾经入狱的人比任何其他机构都更常来寻找工作、寻求制作简历帮助的地方。他可能没有预料到图书馆已经成为了为英语作为第二语言提供更多教学、提供更多公民身份课程的地方，超过了任何其他公共机构。他可能没有预料到图书馆会做
things like, you know, karaoke hours for immigrant communities that want a good place to sing together. I don't know that he would have seen all the teenagers who come to the library at the end of the school day because it's the safest and warmest or if you're in a hot place, coolest place where you can study, apply for college, or just kind of mess around and play video games in a social way. I'll tell you, I saw so many kids come to libraries to play games
一些事情，比如，你知道的，为想要一个好地方一起唱歌的移民社区举办卡拉OK时间。我不知道他是否会看到所有在放学后涌入图书馆的青少年，因为这里是最安全、最暖和的地方，或者如果你在一个炎热的地方，这里是最凉爽的地方，你可以在这里学习、申请大学，或者只是以一种社交的方式闲逛和玩电子视频游戏。我告诉你，我看到很多孩子来图书馆玩游戏，
and like when they played games together, they did it in a way that was very collective and very social. It was not the kind of stereotypical image of a kid in a hole in their, you know, in their own basement being on their own. They were socializing in this very new way. Library is just doing an enormous number of things.
而且就像当他们一起玩游戏时，他们是以一种非常集体、非常社交的方式进行的。这并不是那种刻板印象中一个孩子缩在他们自己的地下室里自娱自乐的形象。他们正在以这种非常新颖的方式进行社交。图书馆正在做着极其大量的事情。
And I really think that we fail to recognize how lucky we are to have inherited this institution. I don't know if you saw this, but about a year ago, there was an article that came out in Forbes magazine where an economist argued that libraries are in fact obsolete and said, you know, if you don't show me the cost-benefit analysis that cashes out the value of the library, I think we should stop all the public contributions to them, knock them down and replace them with Amazon stores. And, you know, it was amazing. Like, at first I thought my friends were just trying to troll me
我真的认为我们没有意识到继承了这样一个机构是多么幸运。我不知道你有没有看到这个，大约在一年前，《福布斯》杂志上发表了一篇文章，一位经济学家认为图书馆实际上已经过时了，并说：“你知道，如果你不给我兑现图书馆价值的成本效益分析，我认为我们应该停止对它们的所有公共捐款，把它们砸掉并换成亚马逊商店。”而且，你知道的，太神奇了。起初我以为我的朋友们只是在试图通过在《福布斯》上发表这篇文章来钓鱼
by planting this article in Forbes. I was writing about the library, but then it turned out it was real. And this amazing thing happened. The librarians of the world united and got on Twitter and wrote the most eloquent testimony to the ongoing power of libraries to convene people. And they wrote such amazing things that Forbes literally took the article down the next day. One of the few good things that Twitter has ever done for the world. When I tried to think of what a great social infrastructure is, it's not that libraries
捉弄我，因为我在写关于图书馆的文章，但后来证明这是真的。然后发生了一件神奇的事情。全世界的图书管理员团结起来上了推特，写下了对图书馆持续将人们聚集在一起的力量最雄辩的证词。他们写了如此精彩的东西，以至于《福布斯》第二天就把这篇文章撤下了。这是推特为世界做过的少数几件好事之一。当我试图思考什么是伟大的社会基础设施时，并不是说图书馆
are the only social infrastructure, hardly, but they're just about the most effective social infrastructure that I can imagine. And it is a shame that we don't make more of them by maintaining them or updating them in the way that they deserve. I mean, because they're still radical and innovative today. That's what's so amazing about them. They've reinvented themselves. And one of the things that's so striking about libraries is that the local staff has the capacity and agency to develop programming that works for the community that they're in. Right. There's no strong hard rule that says a library has to do X, Y, or Z things.
是唯一的社会基础设施，远非如此，但它们几乎是我能想象到的最有效的社会基础设施。真遗憾，我们没有通过维护或以应有的方式更新它们来更多地利用它们，因为它们在今天是如此激进和创新。这就是它们如此神奇的地方。它们重塑了自己。图书馆最引人注目的一点是，当地工作人员有能力和自主权来开发适合他们所在社区的规划，对吧。没有任何强硬的硬性规定说图书馆必须做X、Y或Z的事情。
So a library can be, it can lend tools, it can lend seeds, it can lend clothes to people who need better clothes for a job interview. It can do programming in all kinds of languages. I'm sure listeners can think of 50 things that happen in their libraries that I don't even know about. Has the design of these spaces shifted as they've started to accommodate all these other activities besides books and magazines and newspapers? Very much so. Although not as much as it could, if libraries had more resources to play with.
所以图书馆可以是，它可以借出工具，它可以借出种子，它可以为需要面试得体服装的人借出衣服。它可以用各种语言开展规划。我相信听众可以想到50件在他们的图书馆发生而我甚至不知道的事情。当这些空间开始容纳除书籍、杂志和报纸之外的所有这些其他活动时，它们的设计发生了变化吗？变化很大。尽管没有可能发生的变化那么多，如果图书馆有更多的资源可以利用的话。
And one of the things that I've seen is certain municipalities have recognized the value of libraries and have invested in new facilities that can do other things. Most libraries need to have a special room or set of rooms for teenagers now because so many of them come in in the afternoon that they can quite easily take over the place Right and make it difficult for other people so so you see a lot of teen rooms Unfortunately Libraries have become these institutions of last resort for people who slip through the cracks in our safety net and and so like you will find homeless people and people with mental illnesses
我看到的一点是，某些城市已经认识到了图书馆的价值，并投资建设了可以做其他事情的新设施。大多数图书馆现在都需要为青少年提供一个特殊的房间或一组房间，因为下午有太多青少年进来，他们很容易接管这个地方，对吧，并给其他人带来不便，所以你会看到很多青少年房间。不幸的是，图书馆已经变成了我们安全网中漏网之人的最后底线机构，因此你会发现无家可归者和精神病患者
And and people who are really struggling to homeless people and people with mental illnesses and people who are really struggling to get by, oftentimes people with drug addiction, who come into libraries and need a special kind of protection or assistance. And some libraries, including in San Francisco, have really been aggressively experimenting with ways to provide more supportive environments like that. Other countries have made massive new investments in national library buildings that do extraordinary things. The new library in Helsinki is amazing. There's a new library in Calgary that's amazing.
还有那些真正艰难求生的人，通常是那些有毒瘾的人，他们来到图书馆，需要一种特殊的保护或援助。一些图书馆，包括旧金山的图书馆，一直在积极试验各种方法，以提供更多支持性的环境。其他国家已经在国家图书馆建筑上进行了大规模的新投资，做了非凡的事情。赫尔辛基的新图书馆太棒了。卡尔加里有一个很棒的新图书馆。
And some American cities are beginning to invest in libraries as well. But generally speaking, when that happens, we invest in the bright, shiny, central library. That patrons are likely to feel proud of, rather than in the branch libraries, which are really the lifeblood of the system. So in the book, you also talk about crime as an infrastructure issue,
一些美国城市也开始投资图书馆。但总的来说，当这种情况发生时，我们投资的是光鲜亮丽的中央图书馆， patron 们可能会为此感到自豪，而不是分馆图书馆，它们才是这个系统的生命线。所以在书中，你也把犯罪作为一个基础设施问题来讨论，
which was a really kind of subtle nuance on the broken windows theory that I found really intriguing. Yeah, I don't know how much people know about the broken windows theory of policing and crime, but this kind of classic essay at this point from James Q. Wilson and George Kelly. That said that when there were broken windows in a neighborhood, people perceive the broken windows as a sign that no one is organizing the neighborhood, that no one has social control.
这实际上是关于破窗理论的一个非常微妙的细微差别，我觉得非常吸引人。是的，我不知道人们对警务和犯罪的破窗理论了解多少，但这已经是詹姆斯·Q·威尔逊和乔治·凯利的一篇经典文章了。文章说，当一个社区出现破窗户时，人们会认为破窗户是一个信号，表明没有人组织这个社区，没有人进行社会控制。
And the notion is that criminals realized that they could get away with anything in a place like that. And so did. And, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, And, and intriguingly, when the original broken windows article came out, it was used as a justification for bringing lots more police into poor neighborhoods, right? It broke in
这个观点是罪犯意识到他们可以在这样一个地方为所欲为。于是他们就这么做了，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，如果我们对破窗作出的反应不是派遣那么多的警察，而是修理该死的窗户，会怎么样呢？对吧？就像，怎么从来没有人想到过这一点呢？我回过头去，这真的很奇怪。就像我有那个想法时，我回到了最初的文章。
windows theory got us the stop and frisk policing and zero tolerance policing, because the notion was, if you've got disorder, you need to make sure that there's a lot of extra help to keep criminals from doing their thing. And that was a big reason that we have this kind of system of mass incarceration that's really transformed the United States and especially poor neighborhoods. And having spent a lot of time thinking about the power of social infrastructure and physical places,
“破窗理论”给我们带来了拦截盘查执法和零容忍执法，因为当时的观点是，如果你遇到了混乱，你就需要确保有大量额外的帮助来阻止犯罪分子作恶。这也是美国、尤其是贫困社区出现这种大规模监禁制度的一个重要原因。我花了大量时间思考社会基础设施和物理场所的力量，
I found myself asking this question, like what would have happened if we had responded to broken windows, not by sending in so many police officers, but by fixing the damn windows, right? Like, how did nobody ever think of that? And I went back, and it's really weird. Like I went back to the original article when I had that thought.
我不禁在想，如果我们对破窗效应的反应不是派遣大量警察，而是去把该死的窗户修好，会发生怎么样的结果？对吧？怎么会从来没有人想到这一点呢？我回去查了资料，这真的很奇怪。当我产生这个想法时，我回去查阅了最初的那篇文章。
And I found that if you read it closely, the chain of events that leads to this idea that we should send in more police and do zero tolerance policing is, you know, a neighborhood gets abandoned, you know, property gets abandoned. Graffiti goes up, a window is broken, and then it thinks kind of spiral out of control. The neighborhood gets abandoned. Property gets abandoned. Graffiti goes up, a window is broken, and then it thinks kind of spiral out of control.
我发现如果你仔细阅读，导致我们应该派更多警察并实行零容忍警务这一想法的一连串事件是，你知道的，一个社区被抛弃了，你知道的，房产被抛弃了。涂鸦出现了，窗户破了，然后事情就有点失控了。社区被废弃了。房产被废弃了。涂鸦出现，窗户被打破，接着事情就有些失控了。
So why is it that the theory wasn't called the abandoned property theory? It's a horrible title. Broken Windows is an awesome title. We have bowling alone and broken windows. It's great, like catchy phrases that turn out to justify really terrible social policies. And in the case of the broken windows thing, it didn't even work.
所以为什么这个理论不叫废弃房产理论呢？这是一个糟糕的标题。“破窗”是一个棒极了的标题。我们有《独自打保龄球》和《破窗》。太棒了，朗朗上口的短语结果却为真正糟糕的社会政策进行了辩护。而在破窗这件事上，它甚至根本没有起作用。
So we forgot all about the abandoned property part. So I started asking, like, what would happen if we had fixed the windows? If we did fix up that property. And when I asked it turns out that someone else had thought about it much more than I had, there was this team of scientists at the University of Pennsylvania that had been asking a similar question, and they wound up teaming up with the city of Philadelphia, which has tens of thousands of abandoned properties and empty lots, and also the Pennsylvania Horticultural Society,
所以我们把废弃房产的部分忘得精光。所以我开始问，如果我们修好了窗户会发生什么？如果我们真的修好了那个房产。当我提出这个问题时，原来其他人比我想得更多，宾夕法尼亚大学有一组科学家一直在问类似的问题，他们最终与费城这座拥有数万处废弃房产和空地的城市合作，还有宾夕法尼亚园艺学会，
which sounds like an old person's gardening club, but turns out to be this powerhouse operation that helps to control all this vacant land in Philadelphia. And they started one of the most exciting social science experiments that I know of happening right now. And for more than a decade, they've been doing this thing, which is they kind of randomly select blocks where they will make simple interventions. So if there was an abandoned house, they would board up the building and prevent squatters or, you know, potential drug dealers or criminals from from using the the property and if it was an empty lot that would have weeds and debris and
听起来像是个老年人园艺俱乐部，结果却是一个庞大的运营机构，帮助控制费城所有这些空置土地。他们开始了据我所知目前正在进行的最激动人心的社会科学实验之一。十多年来，他们一直在做这件事，他们随机选择一些街区来进行简单的干预。如果有废弃的房屋，他们会用木板封住建筑物，防止擅自居住者、你知道的、潜在的毒贩或罪犯使用该房产；如果是一个长满杂草、碎屑的空地，
All kinds of garbage that would make it a public health hazard they would clean it up Moat down and put in a little pocket park maybe plant a tree put in a bench put a wooden fence there and a little pocket park, maybe plant a tree, put in a bench, put a wooden fence there. And they wanted to see what happened in the places where they made the intervention and what happened in the places that they left alone. And the results were staggering. They achieved almost a 40% decline in gun violence around the abandoned properties that they treated.
充满了各种使其成为公共卫生隐患的垃圾，他们会将其清理干净，修剪草坪，建一个小型口袋公园，也许种一棵树，放一张长椅，装上木栅栏，建一个小型口袋公园，也许种一棵树，放一张长椅，装上木栅栏。他们想看看他们进行干预的地方发生了什么，以及他们不闻不问的地方发生了什么。结果令人震惊。他们在处理过的废弃房产周围实现了近40%的枪支暴力下降。
And that's a staggeringly high number, right? To get that. And that has been durable over the course of a decade. What's more, they hooked up heart rate monitors to people who live in those neighborhoods. And they found that even for a resident, when you walk by an untreated property, just in a abandoned place that was left to become a site of debris, people's heart rates really spiked dramatically. And of course, we know that stress-related diseases are especially high in poor neighborhoods that have a lot of abandonment. But when people walk by a place that's been treated
这是一个惊人数字的高度，对吧？取得这样的成果。并且在十年的时间里，这一成果一直保持着持久性。更重要的是，他们将心率监测器连接到生活在这些社区的人们身上。他们发现，即使对于居民来说，当你走过一处未处理的房产时，仅仅是一个被任其变成垃圾场的废弃地方，人们的心率真的会急剧飙升。当然，我们知道与压力相关的疾病在有大量废弃现象的贫困社区尤其高。但当人们走过一个经过处理
and turned into a little park, their heart rate hardly changes. And again, it's just like an amazing thing to achieve with a modest investment in social infrastructure. And did the crime just move from one place to another or did it just reduce in total? Yeah, so that's what they thought was going to happen that you fix up one block and crime
并变成小公园的地方时，他们的心率几乎没有变化。再次重申，通过对社会基础设施进行适度的投资就能取得这样的成果，这真是一件了不起的事情。犯罪行为只是从一个地方转移到了另一个地方，还是总量减少了？是的，所以这就是他们以为会发生的事情，你修复了一个街区，犯罪行为
just bounces to the next one. But the amazing thing here is it didn't. It turns out that, we think of crime as being about bad individuals doing bad things and know that that's part of the story. But a lot of crime is just situational, right? Like if you create a city with lots of places where no one is in control and no one feels a sense of responsibility and people have a hard time managing things,
只是弹跳到下一个街区。但这里令人惊奇的是，它没有。事实证明，我们认为犯罪是关于坏人做坏事，并且知道这是故事的一部分。但很多犯罪只是情境性的，对吧？如果你创造一个城市，里面有很多地方没有人控制，没有人感到责任感，人们很难管理事情，
you create situations where crime is more likely. But if you take those situations away, the crime just doesn't happen. And so the answer's no. They did not, the crime just doesn't happen. And so the answers no. They did not get the crime bouncing elsewhere. It simply didn't happen. Wow. So I was reading your book and I think about myself
你就创造了犯罪更有可能发生的情境。但如果你把这些情境拿掉，犯罪就不会发生了。所以答案是否定的。他们没有，犯罪就是没有发生。所以答案是否定的。他们没有让犯罪弹跳到别处。它根本就没有发生。哇。所以我当时在读你的书，我在想我自己
in the city and how I interact with people and how my lived experience and my idealized experience sometimes are not in complete concert. and how my lived experience and my idealized experiences sometimes are not in a complete concert. So like if I were a planner, I planned for social infrastructure if I were a mayor, I'd pay for it, but as a person's logging through life, I don't always want to encounter people.
在城市里，以及我是如何与人互动的，以及我的生活经验和我的理想化经验有时并不完全一致。以及我的生活经验和我的理想化经验有时并不完全契合。所以，如果我是一名规划师，我会为社会基础设施做规划，如果我是一名市长，我会为此买单，但作为一个艰难维生的人，我并不总是想遇到人。
And so, so when we build, I live in New York City, man, I get that. I told you. So when we build social infrastructure, how do we make sure we're designing for our true selves and not our idealized selves? Yeah, well, it's my take here that there's no shortage of places where people can hunker down
所以，所以当我们建造时，我住在纽约市，老兄，我懂的。我跟你说过。所以当我们建造社会基础设施时，我们如何确保我们是在为真实的自我设计，而不是为理想化的自我设计？是的，好吧，我的看法是，如今人们可以蜷缩起来
and get their own private space these days. We've created a whole society based on our idealization of privacy and autonomy. I mean, it used to be that families shared bedrooms together. Family shared beds together. Now, I know so many people who moved out of their cities because they felt like their kids needed to have
并获得他们自己的私人空间的地方并不短缺。我们建立了一个完全基于我们对隐私和自主权的理想化的社会。我的意思是，过去家庭是共用卧室的。家庭共用床铺。现在，我认识很多搬出城市的人，因为他们觉得他们的孩子需要有
their own individual bedrooms. Right? I mean, it's just, so, I'm with you that we all need a space for privacy. And in fact, a library is a really amazing social infrastructure in part because it combines, you know, shared tables and programs and activities with little nooks where a person can go and anonymously be in their own head. Right. Right? And a park does the same thing. Right? A park can be a place for collective life,
他们自己的独立卧室。对吧？我的意思是，所以，我赞同你的观点，我们都需要一个属于隐私的空间。事实上，图书馆是一个非常了不起的社会基础设施，部分原因在于它将共用桌子、节目和活动与小角落结合在一起，人们可以在那里匿名地沉浸在自己的思绪中。对吧。对吧？公园也做同样的事情。对吧？公园可以成为集体生活的地方，
and a park can be a place where we go to be like the row and have our own time and space. I think you're right. We always need to be mindful of those things. You know, we don't want to force people out into the public realm, but my sense right now is that the, it's the publicly accessible public realm that's really in short supply. I'm intrigued by this idea of a public ownership and how we convey that. I mean, I think one of the reasons why the pocket parks work and library's work is because we feel like we own them when they're done right.
公园也可以是我们去像罗曼一样拥有我们自己的时间和空间的地方。我想你是对的。我们总是需要牢记这些事情。你知道，我们不想强迫人们进入公共领域，但我的直觉是，现在真正短缺的，是那些可公开访问的公共领域。我对这种公共所有权的理念以及我们如何传达它很感兴趣。我的意思是，我认为口袋公园之所以有效、图书馆之所以有效的原因之一，是因为当它们做得对时，我们觉得我们拥有它们。
You know, we feel like we belong. And that makes everyone closer connected. But also just like they treat the world better when it's ours versus a private space that we can just occupy as long as we are buying that cup of coffee. How do we make sure we make things so that everyone feels like they're really a part of it? Oh, man, that is such a tough question. I've been thinking about it a lot, especially in light of the past year where we've started to see more publicly just how restrictive and exclusive some of
你知道，我们觉得自己属于这里。这让每个人都联系得更紧密。而且就像当这是我们的时候，我们会更好地对待这个世界，而不是像一个私密空间那样，只要我们买着那杯咖啡就能一直占有着。我们如何确保我们制造的东西能让每个人都觉得他们真正是其中的一部分？哦，天哪，这是一个多么难的问题啊。我一直在思考这个问题，特别是在过去这一年的光景下，我们开始更加公开地看到一些地方是多么具有限制性和排他性
our, like, you know, most valued semi-public spaces can be, like, remember that video that's circulated about the two African-American guys in Philadelphia who went into a Starbucks. And you know, they, like, they went there and tell me if this ever happened to you, like, you go to meet somebody and they're late. Yeah. Like, all the time. Have you ever experienced that? Right?
我们最受珍视的半公共空间可能会……你知道的，还记得那段在网上流传的视频吗？两个非裔美国人在费城走进了一家星巴克。你知道的，他们去了那里，告诉我这有没有在你身上发生过，比如，你去见某个人，而他们迟到了。是的。比如，经常这样。你经历过这种情况吗？对吧？
So these guys go and like, I know that I've sat in Starbucks waiting for someone who doesn't show up for 10, 20, 30 minutes an hour and no one's ever said anything to, like, you know, white professional academic guy. But, but like, these two guys, guys, they don't get asked to buy something, they don't get politely asked to leave, they get arrested for being in this shared space, this crazy thing. And so in that context, people who get in feel entitled and privileged, and there are a whole bunch of people who are left out all together. And that alerted me to the sense that like,
所以这些人去了，而且，我知道我曾在星巴克坐着等一个不出现的人10、20、30分钟甚至一个小时，从来没有人对像，你知道的，白人专业学者这样的人说过什么。但是，但是这两个人，他们没有被要求买点东西，他们没有被礼貌地请离开，他们因为在这个共享空间里而被逮捕了，这太疯狂了。所以在这种背景下，那些觉得自己有权利和特权的人，还有一大群完全被冷落的人。这让我意识到……
to the extent that our public space and our public realm, our shared spaces, are part of the commercial economy, they are really restrictive, right? Like you have to be able to pay, you have to be let in. And there are a lot of places, especially like in gentrifying neighborhoods and cities, where people just
就我们的公共空间和公共领域、我们的共享空间是商业经济的一部分而言，它们真的是限制重重的，对吧？就像你必须付得起钱，你必须被允许进去。而且有很多地方，特别是在正在经历绅士化的社区和城市里，人们只是
know that they're not welcome, because it costs $7 for coffee or $9 for ice cream, or they don't take cash at all, they're only for people with credit cards. I have to say, one of the most amazing things I observed in the public libraries where I spend time is that There are places where This impossible community of people who are so different from one another come together and all kinds of people who have real struggles come too because There's just not space for them anywhere else and in the year that I spent going to the library Pretty much every day. I can count on one hand the number of times
知道他们是不受欢迎的，因为一杯咖啡要7美元，或者一筒冰淇淋要9美元，或者他们根本不收现金，只为有信用卡的人服务。我必须说，我在度过时间的公共图书馆里观察到的最神奇的事情之一就是，有些地方，这些彼此截然不同、不可能聚在一起的社区人们聚在了一起，各种各样生活艰难的人也来了，因为其他地方根本没有他们的空间。在我去图书馆的这一年里，几乎每天都去，我可以屈指可数地数出
that the police had to be called in and that there was a real security concern because people, you know, we're acting out towards one another. Most of the time when people go into libraries, they recognize that they are being respected and dignified and honored. And I think it brings out the best in us. So I think it's a great question. What kinds of public places can do that, can exalt our experience in the world in the way that a library can? And what can we do to make sure
警察不得不被叫来并且存在真正安全隐患的次数，因为人们，你知道的，对彼此有出格的行为。大多数时候，当人们走进图书馆时，他们认识到自己受到了尊重、尊严和荣誉。我认为这激发了我们最好的一面。所以我认为这是一个很好的问题。什么样的公共场所能做到这一点，能像图书馆那样提升我们在世界上的体验？我们能做些什么来确保
that the places that we've built do that even better? Is there any momentum towards more social infrastructure? I mean, do we require a modern day Carnegie? Do we require our government to do more? Do we require us to just demand more? What is it going to take? And do you see the evidence that it's happening? It's an urgent question.
我们建造的地方能把这一点做得更好？朝着更多的社会基础设施有任何动力吗？我的意思是，我们需要一个现代的卡耐基吗？我们需要政府做更多事情吗？我们需要我们自己去要求更多吗？这需要付出什么？你看到它正在发生的证据了吗？这是一个紧迫的问题。
You know, how are we going to pay for this? And it's true that Carnegie was a philanthropist and philanthropic dollars went to build a bunch of libraries. And I closed the book by noting how strange it is that we live in a world with these kind of titans of the information age who have made billions of dollars with things like social media and computing and who haven't made contributions to social infrastructure in a way that I would like to see. In fact, one of the really off-putting things for me about Mark Zuckerberg's use of the concept social infrastructure is that he's been promoting Facebook as the social infrastructure he uses
你知道，我们要如何为此买单？诚然，卡耐基是一位慈善家，慈善资金用于建造了一堆图书馆。我在书的结尾指出，生活在一个拥有这种信息时代巨头的世界里是多么奇怪，他们通过社交媒体和计算等东西赚了数十亿美元，却没有以我希望看到的方式对社会基础设施做出贡献。事实上，马克·扎克伯格对社会基础设施概念的使用让我感到非常倒胃口的一点是，他一直在推广Facebook作为他所使用的社会基础设施
that language for the 21st century and says, you know, Facebook is where we'll go from meaningful interactions. And yet, if you go to the Facebook campus in Manlo Park, like no one on earth has spent more money on actual physical social infrastructure than Mark Zuckerberg. Like it's a workers paradise there, right? Like the bike paths and the yoga studios and the shared spaces for serendipitous encounters and the massages for people while they're coding at their desks like it's amazing there.
21世纪的语言，并说，你知道，Facebook是我们寻求有意义的互动的地方。然而，如果你去曼洛帕克的Facebook园区，世上没有人比马克·扎克伯格在实际的物理社会基础设施上花费更多的钱。就像那是那里工人的天堂，对吧？比如自行车道、瑜伽室、供偶遇的共享空间，以及人们在办公桌前编写代码时的按摩，那里的环境棒极了。
And in fact, the people who work in those companies don't let their kids go on the devices because they know how dangerous a phone can be as social infrastructure. So on the one hand, I kind of want to see the big philanthropists of our time spend more on things like libraries. But I also know in my heart that philanthropic dollars are ultimately inadequate and they're kind of like randomly distributed to the places where the philanthropists tend to spend time. And that if we're ever really going to
事实上，在这些公司工作的人不允许他们的孩子使用这些设备，因为他们知道手机作为社会基础设施是多么危险。因此，一方面，我有点希望我们这个时代的各大慈善家能在图书馆之类的事情上花更多钱。但我内心也深知，慈善资金最终是不够的，它们有点像随机分配给慈善家倾向于消磨时间的地方。而且如果我们真的要
make this work, it's going to have to be through a public commitment, like a major public works program. And I think it's just a matter of time until we do that. But clearly, we're going to have to muster up the collective will for it. And we certainly can't rally for it and call for it if we don't have a name for the thing that we want.
让这起作用，它将不得不通过公共承诺来实现，比如一个重大的公共工程项目。我认为我们这样做只是时间问题。但显然，我们将不得不为此鼓起集体意志。如果我们对我们想要的东西连个名字都没有，我们当然无法为之集会和呼吁。
And that's one reason why I hope that social infrastructure is sticky, that it means something. Because we have no problem paying for infrastructure when it comes to the things that we think of as critical. The infrastructure is like one of the few things that both Trump and Clinton agreed that we needed a few years ago. I just hope we can recognize the need for social infrastructure and find some way to persuade the people who are running our government that without their support it will never happen. It's we need like a social infrastructure week. I'm thinking more like a decade. Exactly. At least.
这也是我希望社会基础设施具有粘性、具有某种意义的原因之一。因为当谈到我们认为是关键的事情时，我们在为基础设施付费方面没有任何问题。基础设施就像特朗普和克林顿几年前都认为我们需要少数几件事情之一。我只希望我们能认识到对社会基础设施的需求，并找到某种方法来说服管理我们政府的人，没有他们的支持，这一切永远不会发生。我们需要一个类似社会基础设施周的东西。我觉得更像是一个十年。没错。至少。
And look like if you look at any report that comes from the World Bank, or even our own government, they recognize that we will soon be spending tens of billions of dollars, and then hundreds of billions of dollars, and trillions of dollars internationally to build new infrastructure.
听着，如果你看一下世界银行甚至我们自己政府发布的任何报告，他们都会认识到，我们很快将花费数百亿美元，然后数千亿美元，并在国际上花费数万亿美元来建设新的基础设施。
Because the systems that we have to keep us in the modern world simply don't work. And we know it's true in the case of the subway and we know it's true in the case of the power grid. And it's my observation that it is also true, maybe even more true in the case of our social infrastructure. They have just been absolutely neglected.
因为我们拥有的让我们保持在现代世界的系统根本无法运作。我们知道在地铁的情况下这是真的，我们也知道在电网的情况下这是真的。据我观察，这也是真的，在我们的社会基础设施的情况下可能更是如此。它们简直被完全忽视了。
And if we want to support the kind of social life that we all need, you know, regardless of our politics, regardless of our income, you know, regardless of where we live, that we all need to live well and be better connected with each other, you know, we're going to have to find a way to invest in it. Eric Clemmberg's book is called Palaces for the People. You will enjoy reading it and nodding vigorously along with it. You can get it at a bookstore near you or you can also get it from the library. Next, Avery Trollfman joins me in the studio for a little announcement. Stay with us. So I'm in the studio with Avery Trollfman, producer at 99% invisible and creator and host
如果我们想支持我们所有人需要的这种社会生活，你知道，不管我们的政治立场如何，不管我们的收入如何，不管我们住在哪里，我们都需要好好生活并彼此更好地联系，你知道的，我们将不得不找到投资它的方法。埃里克·克里嫩伯格（Eric Klinenberg）的书名为《为人民的宫殿》（Palaces for the People）。你会喜欢阅读它并对之大力点头赞同的。你可以在你附近的书店买到它，也可以从图书馆借到。接下来，艾弗里·特劳夫曼（Avery Truffman）来到演播室与我一起做一个小宣布。留在这里。所以我和《99%隐形》的制作人、创意人兼主持人艾弗里·特劳夫曼在演播室里
of articles of interest, and we have an announcement. We do. Boy, this is interest and we have an announcement. We do. Boy, this is the wind up to the announcement. I recently went on a tour of the San Francisco Goodwill Processing Center, like where when you donate something to Goodwill and you're in the San Francisco area, it goes to this warehouse,
《兴趣的物品》（Articles of Interest），我们有一个宣布。我们确实有。天哪，这就是宣布的铺垫。我最近去参观了旧金山的古德威尔（Goodwill）处理中心，就像你在旧金山地区时把东西捐给古德威尔，它会去这个仓库一样，
to get sorted and moved to the place to the location where it will be sold. And it was this huge kind of hanger of a building. And there was so much activity. And they are running out of space. The amount of stuff they have has increased by 30 percent because of Marie Condon. Because everyone, and also because it was the end of the year, and everyone wants to get their like donations in for taxes
进行分类并运送到将被出售的地点。这是一个巨大的机库式的建筑。里面有那么多的活动。而且他们的空间快用完了。由于玛丽·孔多 (Marie Kondo)，他们拥有的东西数量增加了30%。因为每个人，还因为那是年底，每个人都想把他们的捐赠搞定以用于税收
but they just were running out of space to put and it was just raxon raxon raxon raxon raxon raxon raxon raxon raxon close and It's pretty overwhelming when you see it all in one place. Yeah, and it seems to me in this world of ours There has never been a better time to talk about what you wear and really take a look at what you own and think about it. Which you did in your groundbreaking podcast within a podcast called Articles of Interest, which is now not just a podcast within a podcast, it has its own feed. That's our announcement. So, you know, you can go onto iTunes or Apple
但他们只是快没有空间来放置了，到处都是衣服、衣服、衣服、衣服、衣服、衣服、衣服、衣服。当你亲眼看到这一切集中在一个地方时，感觉相当压抑。是的，在我看来，在我们这个时代，从来没有比现在更好的时机来谈论你穿什么，真正审视你拥有的东西并思考它。正如你在名为《兴趣的物品》的播客内的播客中所做的那样，现在它不仅是播客中的播客，它有了自己的订阅源。这就是我们的宣布。所以，你知道，你可以去iTunes或Apple
podcasts or radio public or Google Play and download all the episodes of Articles of Interest. We did this because we know that many of you heard them and if you're listening to 99PI right now means you already subscribed to 99PI, but we wanted them available, you know, almost like for archive purposes. So you can just go listen to articles of interest and you can share that. And I think that's really, really great. So we have a new feed available for that. And also on the feed is the theme song, which so many people have asked about.
播客、Radio Public或Google Play下载《兴趣的物品》的所有单集。我们这样做是因为我们知道你们中的许多人都听过它们，如果你现在正在听《99PI》，意味着你已经订阅了《99PI》，但我们希望它们可用，你知道，几乎就像为了归档目的。所以你可以直接去听《兴趣的物品》，并且你可以分享它。我认为这真的非常非常棒。所以我们为此提供了一个新的订阅源。并且订阅源上还有主题曲，许多人都在询问这首歌。
It's by Sassami Ashworth. She's amazing. And she has an album out now, but this song, the theme song of Articles of Interest, which is so beautiful and has been stuck in my head for months now, it's so good. And you can only get that, well some fans have uploaded it to YouTube, but if you want to listen to it extremely conveniently on your phone, it's on the feed for Articles of Interest.
它是萨萨米·阿什沃思（Sasami Ashworth）创作的。她太棒了。她现在有一张专辑发行了，但这首歌，《兴趣的物品》的主题曲，是如此美丽，并且已经在我的脑海里盘旋了好几个月了，它太棒了。你只能在——虽然有些粉丝把它上传到了YouTube上，但如果你想在手机上极其方便地收听它，它就在《兴趣的物品》的订阅源上。
So if you go subscribe to Articles of Inter interest right now, you can get all six episodes and maybe you heard them but you should definitely hear them again. I know I heard them a bunch of times and they always reveal more and more because they're sort of densely constructed and they speak to each other in cool ways and you'll notice it more when you listen to it again. And you also on the feed you'll get Sasami'sammi's theme song, which we commissioned, like an original commission for this series, and you'll have them all right there, all like the seven episodes of something to listen to. Also, I need your help because last night when Roman told me
所以如果你现在去订阅《兴趣的物品》，你可以获得全部六集，也许你听过它们，但你绝对应该再听一遍。我知道我听了好几遍，它们总是展现出越来越多的内容，因为它们的结构很紧凑，并且以很酷的方式相互呼应，当你再次收听时你会注意到更多。而且你在订阅源上还会得到萨萨米的主题曲，这是我们委托创作的，就像是为这个系列专门定制的原创委约作品，你将把它们都放在那里，所有大约七集的节目都可以收听。另外，我需要你的帮助，因为昨晚当罗曼告诉我
that the feed was up, I went and I checked it out, right away, and if you just go to the iTunes store and you search articles of interest, it'll come up. And it already had, like at the moment it was born, someone gave it a review and it's a one-star review and it just says, yo, this podcast is insufferable, which is just a great welcome to the world of podcasting. Oh, God.
订阅源上线了，我马上去查看了，如果你直接去iTunes商店搜索《兴趣的物品》，它就会出现。它已经有了，就在它诞生的那一刻，有人给它写了一条评论，这是一条一星差评，上面只写着：‘哟，这个播客太难受了。’这真是对播客世界的热烈欢迎。哦，天哪。
So here's the deal, here's what you're in charge of now, like you, fair listener, go review articles of interest, give it five stars. I mean, the thing is that, articles of interest was called out at the end of last year as the best podcast of the year from a lot of people. And if you're one of those people that admired it as much as we did here and people did largely out in the world besides this guy who said, yo, it's unsuffable. Go give it five stars, go download it again, share it with your friends. This is an easy way to do it instead of going to, I don't know, I don't even know what episode it was, like episode 310 to 311316 or something.
所以情况是这样的，这就是你现在负责的，像你这样公正的听众，去给《兴趣的物品》写评论，给它五星好评。我的意思是，问题在于，《兴趣的物品》在去年年底被许多人评为年度最佳播客。如果你是那些像我们这里的人一样钦佩它、以及除了这个说‘哟，太难受了’的家伙之外世界上绝大多数人一样钦佩它的人之一。去给它五星好评，再去下载一次，分享给你的朋友。这是一个简单的方法，而不是去，我不知道，我甚至不知道那是哪一集，比如第310集到311、316集左右。
It's better in the feed now. Now it's all buried, but now you can go find it on its own, subscribe it. Let's run to the top of the charts and let people find it again. I would really, really enjoy that. So go out there and spread the word people. Or it can be any number of stars you want. I just want more variety. Like one star of you. It should be five.
现在在订阅源里更好了。现在它都被埋没了，但现在你可以自己去找到它，订阅它。让我们冲上排行榜的顶端，让人们重新找到它。我会非常非常开心的。所以大家快去广而告之吧。或者它可以是你想要的任何数量的星星。我只是想要更多样化。就像一星差评。它应该全是五星。
We need to bury this guy, this yo guy. And I'm certain it's a guy. But this is the thing. This is the thing. He rated it so quickly. Yeah. I don't know if he hates me or loves me. Like he found this somehow.
我们需要埋了这个家伙，这个“哟”家伙。我确信这是个家伙。但事情就是这样。事情就是这样。他评价得太快了。是的。我不知道他是在恨我还是爱我。他不知怎么找到了这个。
He's something. He's amazing. Go pile in a bunch of five star reviews that would make me happy and get the average up and share it with people and go listen to the episodes again because they're really, really great. So anyway, so that's our little, so that's our announcement.
他真是个人才。他太棒了。大家快去刷一堆五星好评吧，这会让我很高兴，把平均分拉高，和大家分享，再去听听这些单集节目，因为它们真的非常非常棒。总之，这就是我们的，这就是我们的宣布。
Happy birthday, articles of interest. Or happy independence day. And you mentioned going to Goodwill. So that's how it ends. Happy birthday, articles of interest. Happy Independence Day. And you mentioned going to Goodwill, and so that means you're probably doing stuff. I'm doing stuff. I'm stepping around. Listen, listen, listen. To announce one's intentions is ultimately to broadcast one's failures.
生日快乐，《兴趣的物品》。或者独立日快乐。你提到了去古德威尔。所以这就是结局。生日快乐，《兴趣的物品》。独立日快乐。你提到了去古德威尔，这意味着你可能在搞事情。我在搞事情。我在四处走动。听着，听着，听着。宣布一个人的意图最终就是广播一个人的失败。
I don't want to jinx anything. So just know that there's also stuff going on with articles. Anyway, you'll hear more about that over time. All right, thanks, Avery. Thanks, Roman. ["Many Days"] 99% of the visible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald, music by Sean Rihall.
我不想带来坏运气。所以只要知道关于《物品》也有事情在进行。无论如何，随着时间的推移你会听到更多关于这个的消息。好的，谢谢艾弗里。谢谢罗曼。[“许多天”] 本周的《99%隐形》由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）制作，肖恩·里霍尔（Sean Rihall）配乐。
Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes senior editor Delaney Hall, Sharifusif, Avery Trollman, Terrem Mazza, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Lee, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco, and produced, Unradio Row, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org.
凯蒂·明格（Katie Mingle）是我们的高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监。团队其他成员包括高级编辑德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、谢里夫·优素福（Sharif Youssef）、艾弗里·特劳夫曼（Avery Truffman）、杰里姆·马扎（Jerem Mazza）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Lee）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）以及我——罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的项目，在美丽、市中心的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市制作，Unradio Row。《99%隐形》是来自PRX的Radio Topia成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的激烈独立的集体。请在 radiotopia.fm 上找到它们。你可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与关于本节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上@Roman Mars，也可以@本节目 99PI org。
We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But if you want links to Eric's book and the articles of interest feed, book no further than 99PI dot org. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但如果你想要埃里克的书和《兴趣的物品》订阅源的链接，只需访问99PI点org。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。